you
[Music]
welcome your to Microsoft and in Redmond
you've been here as part of our
Microsoft ai's distinguished lecture
series and gave a fabulous talk
yesterday to a standing-room-only crowd
here and spent time with our researchers
and engineers and I want to thank you
for taking this opportunity to share
some of your insights with a broader
community so we're here in in part
because of the role that you've played
as an amazing leading figure in a real
transformation that deep learning has
enabled in the last five to ten years
and you think about the capabilities
that computers now have from speech
recognition speech generation image
analysis even real-time translation from
one language to another and there's a
whole generation of people growing up
who think that you can pick up a phone
say something and something magical will
happen most of the time 10 years ago
that was inconceivable and you must be
proud excited exhilarated by this but
you've also this is not something that
you've taken up recently you've been in
the field for a number of years I did
the wrong math yesterday and said 25
years but you corrected me and said it's
30 years can you say a little bit about
you know what's motivated you over the
years to continue to think about human
intelligence machine intelligence and
how we can leverage insights from from
both of those right so when I read these
first neural net papers around 1985 1986
it was passion I mean like I didn't know
what to do for my grad studies and
suddenly I knew so these are the
rumelhart McClellan and early papers in
10 so Jeff Fenton was a huge inspiration
for me and yeah the whole connectionist
group and the PDP book was my Bible the
two volumes the two volumes yes and one
of the reasons I was attracted beyond
the AI and
my adolescent interest for science
fiction was the idea that by studying
this field not only we would get better
understanding of intelligence for
building machines that could be useful
for humans but also will help us to
understand our own intelligence as
intelligence is something so central to
what humans means you focus mostly on
the former of those you still have a
deep passion for the the lab yeah I mean
obviously I had to make a choice and I
was more of a nerd somebody you know
attracted to psychology and things like
this but over the years probably again
following the inspiration from Geoff
Hinton I've always kept close proximity
to neuroscientists scientists as you may
know we set up this program Seafire
program which brings together AI machine
learning and searchers with
neuroscientist and and and and kind of
scientists can you say a little bit
about your thesis because in many ways
it bears a at least a surface level
resemblance to many of the things that
are going on today
sure so so in in my thesis which I
started in 1986 well actually that was
the master's thesis and I did the PhD in
Canada we do Masters in Peach to you so
and I finished in 91 I was so during
this five years I was working on speech
recognition using recurrent neural nets
with a sort of convolutional
architecture was before the modern
architectures obviously and any
probabilistic models hidden Markov
models with the neural and and the
probabilistic pieces being integrated
that was my main contribution how to
train these things properly and it gave
me a lot of hands-on experience with the
difficulties of
nets and in particular I stumbled upon
the the difficulties are training
recurrent Nets on long sequences and a
few years later I published a number of
papers on my subject which became very
very well so I don't know so in in the
last 10 years we've really seen a
transformation of some of those ideas
and and roots take place what do you
think the top two or three things are
either technical or social that have
enabled that that have enabled the the
amazing revolution that we've seen in
the last decade or so in deep learning
well these things have been said before
by many people of course there's a
alignment of planets and it's it's been
technical progress on the algorithms the
amount of data the computing power if we
focus on the algorithms there's of
course what gave them that the name deep
learning depth which has been an intense
subject of study from the beginning and
and of interest do you know why would it
help and and this idea that I continue
pushing today that what we should be
striving for our machines that discover
better representations that are more and
more abstract and the other idea that we
had at the beginning was that by
stacking these layers on top of each
other we will build more complex
abstractions on top of simpler ones so
so that's a very central thing and and
now we understand it better
mathematically theoretically but there
were a few really important little
technical things that completely changed
the way we're approaching applications
and our success in in many cases such as
the use of rectifiers that the
revolutions and actually my students
have jiggler Roy and I were the first to
show that hey if you use these piecewise
linear networks you can really train
deep nets whereas if you had the
hyperbolic tangent it didn't work
so and we don't yet understand we don't
have the theory to understand that yet
and this was 2010 there's still lots of
work to be done
yeah yeah and and then we say another
great contribution to today's success
for many models not not for computer
vision but more in the language side is
the use of attention mechanisms to say
as you said that's been crucial for
machine translation for example but it's
it's now used everywhere we want to
handle more complicated data structures
and then simple images or or synchro's
or sequences so that's that's
interesting because it's changing these
these things are really changing the
face of neural nets as I was using them
in the late 80s during my PhD it's there
used to be pattern recognition machines
and the first successes with speech
recognition for example and then with
with object recognition and images we're
really focused on this pattern
recognition ability right but if you
look at what people are doing now and
for example applications in in natural
like machine reading comprehension and
even in complicated models that involve
reinforcement learning our memory these
these notions of attention become really
really useful thanks and you shared
yesterday with us some of your you know
insights about moving from the
remarkable progress we've made in
pattern recognition to much higher level
cognitive capabilities in large part by
abstraction and talked about a couple of
what are essentially priors that one can
use to constrain what it is that a an
agent acting in the world would need to
learn can you share some of those broad
ideas in the audience so first of all I
think the idea that machine learning is
built by combining the right priors and
of course you know bringing the data on
top of that
is something that is not sufficiently
appreciated some some people think that
oh we got this magical Universal recipe
that's grateful for all of our problems
no there's this dream of tabula rasa a
machine learning but it just doesn't
make much sense and instead what we're
doing in practice is coming up with
sometimes very domain-specific and
hopefully more general constraints or a
priori or assumption that helps
structure the model so that they will
generalize very very well and in fact
death itself is an example of things
like that and what I talked about
yesterday are priors that we can put in
the architecture the training framework
that hopefully help the learners mostly
unsupervised but it could be also
supervised door reinforcement learning
to discover better representations and
better means that in the represented
space you could hopefully predict more
easily those predictions could involve
very few variables so this is the
consciousness prior or these variables
would correspond closely to aspects of
the world that can be controlled by the
agent so these are the kinds of ideas
that that I'm exploring these days and
again to Poppa level a bit the the goal
of a lot of this work is really to
enable machines to come from some of the
very simple and perceptual tasks that
they they do very well that now to
achieving kind of the level of higher
level abstraction and common sense that
even toddlers yeah we are far from
building machines that have the learning
capability of toddlers we can we can do
a lot of engineering to solve specific
problems and bring in tons of data and
do a lot better than toddlers or
sometimes even better than adults right
but but toddlers are still hugely better
quickly learning new tasks quickly
learning language which is one of the
things I'm interested in
and we don't know how to manage that so
one thing that I think we need to pay
more attention to is some of the older
ideas from AI and cognitive science
which have been sort of forgotten
forgotten and with all this modern-day
planning and we need to find a way to
augment the deep learning concepts that
have been very successful with some of
the objectives that that the eye has set
itself to solve without losing all of
the advantages of better generalization
and so on capturing what looks like
intuition which current deep learning is
giving us so do you think that involves
a combination of neural and symbolic
architectures or taking ideas from from
each of those what do you think of the
architecture so there was a popular
there was a popular set of papers I mean
in interest in in the 90s trying to
marry the neural with the symbolic kind
there was like workshops and conferences
and so on it didn't really work and I
think maybe the mistake was to try to
build some sort of hybrid where as I'm
thinking more about a hybrid at a more
abstract level where we take the
concepts that have the principles have
worked well in one case and in the other
case and how do we build architectures
that combine these advantages that for
example introduce in things like you
know nets the notion of indirect
reference which is central to symbolic
processing right and it's quite feasible
to design architectures that have this
just that people haven't explored that
very much
so when you say indirect defferent the
reference you mean things like may your
sense of objects and yes so-and-so am a
mess names right so so a name is
something you can reuse in different
contexts and that you can assign values
you can
you can do computation on the name
itself yeah right so so once you bring
the notion of name in the neural net
world it becomes just something we are
familiar with like embeddings yeah
because we want to be able to name a
community large set of things so now we
see this kind of marriage coming because
until you're making initial strides and
in in in this area and it seems like a
really difficult challenge partly
because we don't know what the objective
functions are partly because or they
distribute it over time in many
scenarios yeah can you just speak a
little get folks a glimmer of I sure of
what the future might hold in that area
so what we're trying to do is also move
machine learning away from the raw
perceptual space where all of our
current training objectives are located
like like hood or even the Gantt
objectives they're all like in pixel
space instead if you if you consider
what humans value how humans plan how we
we check that our predictions are good
and what kind of predictions we're
making it's all happening in this
abstract space right
we don't make T to T plus one
predictions and unfold all of this we'd
like directly predict things in some
vague future and we do it in this in
this very abstract space which doesn't
need to describe every pixel so so this
endeavor with with for example the the
consciousness prior is is trying to
design representation learning
mechanisms that where the objective
function is is defined in that space and
and that could be used for example in
reinforcement learning where planning or
unfolding into the future doesn't need
to be happening in you know like playing
a movie in your head that's not what's
happening
people's minds right but but rather
something abstract that that can refer
to only some he only needs to refer to
some aspects of the world and not every
little detail of it
so is work for example in program
induction central to these ideas or is
that a different way of approaching some
of these you know the ability to act in
the world understand the consequences of
your actions predict what might happen
right so I think in program induction
there is an approach in which we are
working purely syntactically which like
we're doing with our current deep
learning where we are modeling sequences
of characters that somehow do correspond
to programs and I don't believe this is
gonna work I think for program induction
and as well for generally I what we need
is grounded language learning in other
words that the learner figures out at
the same time as it's learning the
language like that the symbols that are
being manipulated is learning what they
refer to in the case of program
reduction that would be what the
computation corresponds to and then
learns to somehow reason and and and act
with with that knowledge in in in
general language learning I think this
is something that's been discussed for
many years and I see more and more
papers in that direction I'm very
encouraged by by that direction from the
community and and I want to push that ok
ok so this is a I have a few general
questions that I want to pop to I mean
thank you for sharing some of the
insights about you know how you got into
this area your decade-long pursuit and
in understanding how people learn using
inspirations from that to support the
development of more intelligent machines
but I want to focus on a couple of other
things so one would be you right now in
Montreal as a professor at the
University of Montreal as the head of
the miele or a broader organization
and there's a I'm not important member
in this community have seen lots of
students and and lots of collaborators
kidding is there any advice that that
you can offer to new people who are
interested in the field both at a
technical level so maybe people who
would develop the next algorithms but
also people who are thinking about how
to use some of the insights shape
insights for their problems so first of
all there's a lot of information about
AI machine learning deep learning
enforcement letting available out there
for free I often get undergrad coming to
me from poor countries even who got a
lot of their information from the
internet there's so many things
tutorials videos papers of course
everything is an archive in our field
that's amazing and an libraries open
source code so there's a lot of
opportunity to learn by yourself and if
you can afford a GPU card even like a
cheap one you can actually do quite a
lot in terms of learning you want people
to compete in some of these harder
benchmarks we can learn a lot you can
you can understand how neon that
training is happening so there's a lot
that an individual who's motivated and
has Basics in computer science and math
can actually learn by themselves that
being said I see an amazing progression
of say some of those students who are
coming to labs like mine and after six
months were year or two years of working
in a group and and and there's this
synergy that happens in the learning the
presence of people who know more than
you environment in which you can speak
freely you can express your ideas and
not feel judged right
I think transform these people into
researchers very quickly and and so if
you have a chance to go in in a
existing group I think it could be a big
step in your learning so this is this is
why students do grad studies and I know
these days it might be tempting for many
people to directly go from undergrad or
master's level training to industry but
you don't necessarily get that if you're
gonna especially become an engineer who
applies these things so depending on
where you want to go I think it's
something to think about
so it sounds like foundational skills
hands-on practice yeah for people who
are more maybe research inclined even
being part of a larger intellectual and
open and sharing community and reading
reading okay reading reading I mean this
is not new any scientist will tell you
you can't even stay up of your science
if you don't read like at least 20% of
your time and in our field things are
moving so fast I can't keep up with
everything that's that's being written
obviously so this is a social network I
get to know what to read because I talk
to other people and I tell them oh I
read this and you know you should read
it and some of that happens online so so
reading and and getting inspiration like
reading groups in order to have guidance
about what to read is really important
there are nice things like open review
net where people in are fielding and the
ICL our community submit their papers
and then anyone can comment and you can
read the reviews online this is this is
amazing this is great it allows for more
participation and allows for people to
see what the process of submitting
papers and reviewing and analyzing
what's going on and and also just
knowing okay I probably don't want to
read this oh I didn't expect this I
should really read it you don't need to
read the whole paper to get a sense of
what's what's in there you also learn a
lot by people's comments on yes a person
it's yeah you know it's really
interesting to see some of that in the
open and you have not as common
so that for better or worse for better
words there are positives and negatives
yes
actually wanted the reflecting about the
changes that have happened in the you
know last decade to support some real
advancements in in machine learning and
AI one of the things you didn't mention
that I think is is really important in
that you've spent a lot of your energy
supporting is a really open agile and
collaborative environment whether it's
through tools with Theano through the
book that you and Ian Goodfellow and
Aaron Kerrville publish that is one of
the bestsellers on Amazon but also more
importantly the chapters are available
for anybody to read without carrying
that you know necessarily the book
around to to new conferences to focus on
representation learning on the open
review process even publishing early in
archive all of those have created I
think a new energy in AI and and machine
learning that wasn't there before can
can you comment on the only one there no
I didn't it's it's it's a community
thing yeah actually you forgot one thing
okay the late 90s I got submitted in the
revolt of the machine learning journal
board that led to the creation of glr
which is now the okay flagship John so
you've always had this rebel a streak
okay maybe it's an open collaborative
community yes mystery and that has led I
think to a lot of the both of the
insights but also perhaps to a frenetic
and unmaintainable pace so yeah yeah
they're a good size of bedsides
yeah yeah I think overall it's it's
helping the progress of science right
and it's it's helping making science
more accessible as well which is
something I care about so some of what
you're talking about
is associated to with a sense of
responsibility that I think scientists
should have and especially as they
mature in their career that we can give
back and
the things that matter are not just how
many papers we publish it's hard
sometimes for a young graduate student
looking for a position to to appreciate
yeah so let me ask a final question that
that builds on that so it's clear now
that AI is out of its academic box and
really having a profound impact on on
many aspects of society you hear about
it in in all sorts of things ranging
from you know fate news to issues of
fairness accountability and transparency
and ethics do you have any insights
about how we as a research community and
an intellectual community can help shape
those outcomes for the for the better I
think there are many ways in which
researchers in this field can have a
positive contribution to the social
impact and the ethical aspects and how
what we call AI for good how I could be
used for for the good of humanity in
general and I see it's amazing a very
rapid increase in the interest in these
questions over the last 12 months even
two years one of the aspects that I'm
thinking more about these days is how we
should try to shift the kinds of machine
learning problems on which we work
towards like I'm seek recognition on
imagenet towards problems that could
have a big positive impact in the world
and especially problems that companies
traditionally are not really interested
in because there may not be any profit
in the short term
like humanitarian applications so so
that's something I've been thinking
about and and how we could help the
poorest countries with with technology
with machine learning with our skills
how we could help the people in those
countries learn those skills so that
they can help themselves I think there's
a lot that could be done and because
these problems are not necessarily
profit it would be easier for companies
the big the big IT companies to actually
collaborate on these questions than the
traditional applications where they are
really competing against each other so I
let's close on that call to action for
the the machine learning and AI
community to not just continue our
technical excellence but understand how
we can really shape people and society
which is certainly one of our passions
here thank you
so thank you so much for your visit and
for this wonderful talk